c'est comme un cul de sac au quotidien
le manque de ressources dans le milieu
scolaire et criant et Myriam boudro
pilon en sait quelque chose elle
enseigne en quatrième année du primaire
où elle constate au quotidien que la
pénurie personnelle se fait sentir elle
est aussi la mère de trois garçons qui
ont des besoins particuliers on manque
d'outils de temps on était soufflé comme
parent moi je me sens seule là dedans
mais comme enseignante aussi on sent
seul là-dedans même si des fois on a des
formations mais c'est toujours du
surplus de tort du surplus de tâches
elle est en arrêt de travail parce que
les services manquent pour le plus jeune
de ses enfants c'est un service cieux
dans le fond parce que ceux qui ont des
problèmes on peut te servir moindrement
qu'un joueur qui manque dans l'équipe
classe ben vraiment nos enfants le
ressemble d'autant plus
pour l'aqualition des parents d'enfants
a besoin particulier du Québec c'était
une catastrophe annoncée selon la
porte-parole le gouvernement était au
fait de la pénurie personnelle depuis
des années mais il a tardé à agir on
voit c'est la pointe de l'iceberg mais
nous on vit les vagues et les
chamboulements année après année on se
demande finalement ben elle est où la
volonté politique elle est où le les
deux chips politiques pour changer ça je
Bernard drinville nouvellement arrivé en
poste le ministre de l'Éducation Bernard
drinville se dit tout à fait conscient
de la pénurie d'enseignants et personnel
de soutien qui fera le réseau il affirme
que sa main est tendue notamment au
syndicat afin qu'il fasse partie de la
solution si le ménis nous tend la main
nous on va être au rendez-vous parce que
c'est urgent de valoriser la profession
enseignante et la femme il constat sur
le terrain et que la situation est
encore loin de s'améliorer l'instabilité
qui est vécu est un défi de plus encore
une fois pour les enseignants qu'il y a
les parents qui ont besoin d'être
rassurés il y a des élèves qui ont
besoin d'être assurés le ministre de
l'Éducation amorcit une tournée des
écoles primaires et secondaires de la
province pour prendre le pouls et
constater les enjeux dans le milieu son
cabinet affirme que c'est tourné 20%
suivre dans les prochaines semaines ici
qui me permettra au Canada Montréal